voilà qui sonne on entendra ah ouais
ouais bah fiche ça fait des années que
je sais d aller comment combler son
couple sous l'impulsion coup de
téléphone terrestre
non parce que ferais tu peux tu peux
prendre le gâteau frigo parce que y'a un
gâteau cadeaux
[Musique]
et
m
année
le baiia
[Musique]
non non
qu'est ce que je t'ai macinnes wood et
ça un peu c'est très joli on est
vraiment
ils sont fous je crois qu'on va y aller
donc tu fais tout ce qu'il dit les vieux
c'est la carotte trois ans
ça ne te dérange pas dit tu prêtes à
tour annoncé naji complète
[Musique]
un texte je suis mort
le cadre de françois bon anniversaire le
président du conseil
voilà donc en soi s'appelle nana quel
talent mademoiselle n'a participé à la
chaîne cbc ton cadeau françois abbas est
très gentil je veux l'utiliser tout tu
peux faire ce que tu veux tu peux même
ne pas l'utiliser ce qui serait sa 7
vexerait maintenant je ne lis pas un peu
oui
il fixe en ont pu alors navarre est là
un petit moment
on connaissait mes fraises françoise et
ce soir nous on
c
et moi j'aime bien moi non plus
[Musique]
jeunisme en ses murs
ses partisans ont repris
car elle joue les géantes ont demandé à
la nage j'aime bien le françois c'est
françois qui demande mondiale françois
ouimet talent va pas je voudrais vous
dire autre chose c'est que dana
connaissait très bien la chanson
l'allemagne et qu'elle impose des plumes
on n'a pas entendu ce qu'il a dit on le
savait elle l'a dit avant vous elle
voulait son point après c'est tout nadal
alors qu'est ce que tu voulais me
demandez je n'oubliais en finale à vous
les vues si vous me demandez quelle
phase et gémissements comme donna summer
toujours été là pour texter sur les
esclaves des autres que ça marche fort
c'est top cool devant un anniversaire
j'ai hâte que ce soit un débat c'est bon
alors là moi je fais tout pour que vos
poils les mecs fermer vos bulbes
françois marc on va faire unique de
silence soyez gentil françois loin de
marquer
on n'a qu'à faire une idée
je vous envie d'amour
[Musique]
fava
allez voir le jour en fin de vie
les lire
[Musique]
shakespeare désir des idées d'érable
c'est bien
[Musique]
for me for me for business
on y va
alors
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis déjà
est-ce que c'est fait pas il n'est pas
dédicacer vos [ __ ] qu'un bouquet de
fleurs fraîches et les saucissons tout
le monde c'est un bon et cela va là bas
bonjour voila comme esclaves mana ne
sais pas trop je me goure naturel à
l'état d'épave
alors vous avez bien que le conte se
calma plus qu'on peut se passer aux
canaux suivants
c'est donc ça c'est le cadeau de
mon ami corti way offre le café des
winter génial d'ailleurs quand même à
tous qu'on n'a pas fêté mon anniversaire
depuis que j'ai 14 ans jamais jamais au
grand jamais même dans la dignité même
familiale jamais ça ne se fait pas chez
moi j'ai pas fait dès la saison saisons
et demie non non non non j'ai têtu s'est
jetée pensionnaire dans un bel avion
assez rigoureuse
annan a enfin moi je dis ça jamais à
mettre un gros bout on dessus sur
l'excèdent comme la belle était très
poli mais c'est bien mais c'est pas les
gens à prendre goût
un autre cadeau kadéos ouais bah ouais
c'est comment utiliser le canot c'est
comment utiliser nana c'est pas moi
c'est pas loin c'est que faire de votre
esclave je veux utilise comme je vois
que c'est un livre si je vous invite à
lire la brève de comptoir de jean marie
gourio qui est
ils m'ont offert un livre ce qu'est ce
que tu veux que la nappe l'orangé tu
vois alors c'est quoi alors il s'agit de
la nouvelle cuisine pour chiens des
conseils pour leur santé leur équilibre
leur joie de vivre
je voulais juste une petite recette au
hasard c'est la grillade inp hb 85 x 1
kg 250 de vieux grognards au titre au
cuir à soupe d'huile de maïs une passe
et de rigaud et inciteront c'était
l'ancienne prend 14e que je vous épargne
le plus inquiétant c th exiger quoi être
heureux alors on va dire d'être comme
comme si j'osais artus vous dire le
premier mot du livre le dernier alors le
premier mot du livre au chapitre e 1
c'est combien de calories pour composer
le menu idéal du chien en super forme et
ça va fermer le mois antérieur
oui c'est une recette alors raconte pas
si la pâte et verte dernière phrase de
la recette de la pâte et vert pâle 147
quant à la pomme de terre elle sert
juste à épaissir la purée de légumes
elle est facultative ont racheté compris
au monde entier c'est ouvert ça y'a rien
de plus chiant de rien
les nombreux mois ça c'est la première
manifestation de sacy salut
elle le fait est là et on va y aller
j'ai fait le le cadeau le cadeau de
françois c'est aussi un là c'est pas
seulement un esclave c'est aussi un
endroit
ah oui ah bon oui voyait se veut solide
mais personnellement je le trouve je
bois les calculs elle y arrive par garde
freinet rien au boulot normalement si
elle arrive pas il faut les punir
oui oui la ville marie j'ai un briquet
aurait brûlé bout des seins ça c'est un
truc qui sont à temps ça va les gars
super drôle à regarder ça il a donné
l'habitude maintenant c'est moi qu'elle
se fait remarquer
non j'ai pas content
[Musique]
c'est désespérant bon france est sympa
avec les squares même chercher mon père
ça il est beau comme eric vain de
chercher mon pull
là on a les faits comme ça fera cette
fois je trouve qu'il est plutôt comme un
turc hirado frais sur le séant contenir
bien après ces champions
c'est ma cinquième bout des seins non
non c'est un petit dubaï dit faire tout
drôle à s'appelle georges les gens voter
pendant l'appel à georges pour maman et
puis rien moment la nuit aussi les rôles
seront versés aux commissaires certains
rôles qui rend les atteintes à leur
plaisir on s'appelle on a envie de
l'année bon alors sois prudent sur la
route
elle est pas belle la vie
elle joue comme en ce moment tu connais
le chef philippe non je connais pas tu
connais pas ce choc
je connais ton beaucoup plus hostile à
ces manuels away the sun c'est du
théâtre
c'est du théâtre on voyait privé je ne
sais pas du tout bien entendu par la clé
les pêcheurs qui pensent que le théâtre
est morte à voir ce soir tu vas voir ce
soit
et vous avez un local c'est le cas les
nouvelles locales excusait local c'est
nous on a local et c'est vrai qu'il ya
une boîte ça fait ça fait trente ans
qu'elle n'est pas ouverte sous la
nouvelle eve et sous les folies bergères
aussi le nombre de tours à faire il
parle comme un 4/6 bristol une boîte
sous l'autel brut s'agira complexe et
pas les catacombes c'est les boîtes
noires et je la connais la boîte de solo
dal bristol mais sous la voix de l'hôtel
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui a créé gimme some de
l'abîmé
les intrigues non le premier groupe qui
a chanté gimme some levine repris par
les dalton a été nul et là je sais bien
apparemment ça ne lui a pas suffi à leur
bonheur en plus je le sais spencer davis
group
lui a fait du mal il est conscient
[Musique]
comme savadogo quais de seine homeless
toubib du plein bin ça
les métiers où est ce qu elle ne pensons
pas son temps
[Musique]
de l'autre
oui
oooh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non à vannes où garer la bagnole est son
milieu tu fermes ta gueule tu là quant
aux allumettes d'emploi c'est tout de
suite beaucoup plus simple il descend se
reprend après l'été comment ladesou ne
trébuche pas ça rien en dessous fait
voir savoir non mais j'ai pas vu on est
où monsieur melon voilà je crois qu'on
s'est planté un la laisse je le connais
ma lancée on les laisse et christophe tu
l'as tu cherches la rue ces melons n'y a
pas compris j'ai pas bien compris
est-ce que comme j'ai craché leur âge et
la gerbe l'année le boulevard saint
germain si on va trop membrane bon on se
retrouve 6e shot fait jusque là bas bon
aller au bout et puis ça un peu à droite
là bas l'esclave du tas moi j'aimerais
bien que ce soit mon anniversaire aussi
à barret mais tu passes entre les deux
chefs turban c'est ce que je veux comme
cadeau moi tu m'as noël arrière
c'est moi j'ai des caprices qui sont
assez compliqués ne marche pas d'un lac
dans le caniveau à l'extérieur voguant
question en europe là tu rentres dans
les barrières vauban et là tu attends
que je réfléchisse on traverse
[Musique]
je suis le maître de cette écoute et
vous circulez
ça va mon service a bien ben bonsoir et
merci
joyeux anniversaire françois merci
philippe von burg famille et ça ça ne se
prête
[Musique]
auj
mayrand
non
on
j'ai pitié
[Musique]
comment
jégo était là
c'est la grèce
sommes nous
[Musique]
un vrai
dans l'autre
tous les ans
solution et que ceux qui n'auraient pas
cautionner
[Musique]
à
s'ils s'inquiètent pour les colis libre
c'est différent vous à part ses prières
mon enfant c'est denis vous joindre un
mais bien montrer moi votre niveau élevé
chez vous et je m'assure c'est à moi on
n'est pas moi c'est bien celui là
c'est un satyre cgc elle fait ses
excuses pour patrick pêcheurs le petit
peu plus carré en quoi les mains sur la
tête
elle avait à la vérité il ya peu c'est
pour ça qu'il faut lui en coller une
autre jeudi une fameuse les framboisiers
garer sur les sentiers de la perdition
au texte eh bien allez vous vous faire
déshabiller
est-ce que vous tenez tant à savoir ce
que sans l'accord des cités du monde
je pense que la rochette
fauconnet trop sévère avec elle la seule
quand même très gentil d'être peut-être
aidé toujours filles qui s'y colle je
suis désolé mais une école privée
mademoiselle a obtenu libre ce clip sur
l'éco libre je dis bravo et bien hâte et
vous
alors comme ça vous voulez savoir
l'effet que cela fait d'être d'année et
bien aux témoins matt unis olemps
théâtre je dis bravo à perte un peu loin
dans l'école diwan à une pièce de brecht
comme qui dirait qu vraiment les banques
idéal où elle ouvrit la porte est
légèrement favorable je peux venir tâche
en appel ne placent même pas non plus
complètement seigneurs vermines petit
combiné une gare
montrez-vous tels que vous êtes prêt
elle a un animal incapable de résister à
ses pulsions
comment exactement combien s'élève votre
groupe du pitou et
ça
le changement dont ivan fecan n'en avait
pas l'habitude oui bah oui ça donnait ça
devait arriver forcément à moi je
l'avais dit ce temps moi je dis jamais
tu réponds oui mais oui messieurs
récolte ce que tu as mais ça c'est dans
la vie alors maintenant quand découvert
c'est une façon de parler
j'ai perdu ma fille un bel homme qui me
ravit toujours chaud agenouillé vous et
des fichiers avez-vous des chats portez
à votre bouche autre chose que les
glands qui hors d'eux les allées de
notre beau couvent maman j'ai bien il va
sont purifiés tout de même au tram et
votre corps on sait faute à venir
asseyez-vous ma fille et montrez moi
votre langue
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu